[Music]
thank you yeah we should talk about
those lips so can we get a tight shot of
these lips yeah they're that's
what what happened okay what happened
was uh Larry David who I work with on
Curb Your Enthusiasm uh said you
shouldn't do stunts anymore you should
do stand-up comedy so I went to Vegas
and I was in a lounge and I was doing
very well and then a doctor came up to
me after a show Dr Bernie middlekoff and
he said I'm a plastic surgeon I could
give you a little Botox fresh me up so I
went in and I did it and then he said
your lips could use a little work and so
this is what he did I can't have them
changed and it's destroyed my career
because people are laughing at my lips
rather than the jokes so I'm suing him
for 10 million dollars you're suing this
guy for 10 million dollars you say it's
ruined your career yes destroyed your
career how do you know if they're
laughing at you or laughing at the lips
we had a hearing and the judge gave me
three jokes and uh it told me
told me to go on a television show do
the jokes and when the audience laughs
at your lips you'll wind up with the
money if they're laughing the jokes you
want okay so you're my very good friend
and uh I'll do these jokes here and I
know they'll Laugh at My Lips okay all
right this is important the 10 million
dollars in the balance here ladies and
gentlemen you go ahead okay uh man walks
into a bar and sits down there sees a
monkey in a cage and he orders a beer
and he says the bartender what's the
monkey in the cage and he said don't
bother me just drink drink this goes out
for a half hour flight the bartender
says all right I'll show you he opens a
cage the monkey jumps out he takes a
baseball bat and hits the monkey over
the head
the monkey pulls the bartender's pants
down and gives him oral sex
the patron said my God that's amazing
the bartender said you want to try it he
says yeah but don't hit me so hard
They're laughing at the lips not the
joke
yes
a little boy goes to his father who's a
chief a little Indian boy and he said
Daddy
where do Indian children get their names
from and and the chief said from the
last thing the mother sees before she
gives birth that's why your sister's
name magnificent rainbow that's why your
brother's name Running Deer and that's
why your other sister is named Crystal
Water
why do you ask the question two dogs
[Applause]
what are you doing
a woman's very
woman's very afraid the size of her
opening
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I could lose a lot of money here I'm
sorry I'm sorry please tell the tell the
joke a woman's afraid of the size of her
opening so she goes to her mother she's
what am I going to do I'm so big down
there when I marry Harry he's going to
divorce me she says don't worry
sweetheart it runs in the family do what
I did when I married your father go to
the market get some raw liver put it in
there and never know the difference
so they get married they have eight
hours of sex she wakes up he's gone but
there's a note on her pillow says my
darling Harriet to think that I waited
here to consummate our love relationship
makes my heart beat so loudly I'm
surprised it didn't wake you up the only
reason I didn't wake you up my
sweetheart is his son was shining
through the window on your face and you
were like a pot of gold at the end of my
love Rainbow the only reason I'm not
here now darling is I'm at work to make
not enough money to buy you a house a
picket fence will have dogs and children
when the five o'clock dinner bell rings
I will be home like the winged gossamer
of Love In Your Arms your loving husband
Harry
is in the sink
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they're taking this show away from us
you don't care but Andy and I this is
her living
do we know is uh was it you're laughing
at is uh the jokes
or were you laughing at his lips
thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen I got one
more joke
no that's it Super Dave Osborne
everybody we'll take them back Lisa
Kudrow's here when we come back